we have a an old friend who uh who
appeared on my other shows uh several
times but he has yet to be a guest on my
new tbs program okay now he's a cautious
guy
and he has asked could he could he check
out the studio before committing to
being a guest on this show and i thought
well that's prudent that's otherwise
before it's official yeah before it's
official he just wants to check the
space out and see if he'd actually be
comfortable before he commits so please
welcome star of tv and film steve carell
let's get him out here
[Applause]
thanks for joining us uh i i appreciate
having this opportunity to just check
the place out yeah that's fine uh i know
you didn't want to commit so first of
all you gotta you know it's that was a
nice reception so this is where i'd be
sitting this is yeah if you were to be a
guest on the show you'd sit
you'd sit right here so i would sit
there sit there yeah and i would look at
you there yes i'd be
i'll be right here all right i'm just
seeing how my head goes like that okay
and then andy is over here and he's
there hello it's pretty much the way we
used to have it you know so yeah okay
that feels all right yeah and what sort
of uh camera angles are you gonna be
using we can try different ones we have
an array if you'd like some of them yeah
okay so that's a two shot there's a say
okay that's nice okay that's good
um they never use that
um now i have a question i will be
telling when i come on i'll be telling
some sort of
anecdote i'm sure some sort of story um
and i just wanted to know what kind of
reaction you guys would give me if i
were to tell say i'm ending a story
about my son
and i and he he looks at me and he says
well dad why don't you go to summer camp
and you would
oh boy
wow classic yeah all right let me try
um
so this one this one's about my wife and
and so i i come home and i say
wow that was a day and she says yeah
what about mine
[Applause]
we could we could do better on that yeah
um we would have worked it out ahead of
time you can't just throw stuff like
that
are these guys going to be standing
there the whole time that's their band
they'll be there yeah so they will play
me in right they'll play me could i hear
you know what can i just try coming out
yeah and they'll play me into something
yeah i just want to hear what sort of
theme music
ladies and gentlemen steve carell
[Music]
you know what that's nice maybe a little
less of the brass
[Laughter]
less horn everybody says that yeah
everyone says everybody's a little bit
more bass but that
that could work okay now one of the
things when i do a show i usually like
to be 33 feet from the audience
um 33 feet
give or take um
could i check to see how far the
audience is yeah that's fine
so basically
[Applause]
coming right to
here
okay
okay that
that is exactly 33 feet right there
you know what i like this
i like that yeah you like that you like
i do you like the hard lighting thing i
like these two they they high-five me
yeah could they be we can get the same
people here if you come back when i come
back we would get those same and i'll
come over and we'll high-five yeah
okay
okay you know i'm feeling uh
i'm feeling pretty good about it feeling
good about it do you promote like a say
i were to be in a movie yeah
do you ever show clips or
promote a movie like would you help me
in the promotion of a movie that i
was doing yes yes
yes we would help you in that we could
actually if you had a clip we would have
we could show a clip from your movie
could i see you do something like that
yes yeah i could we could try one right
now you want to see us try it sure all
right well let's take a cl look at a
clip from your brand new movie uh crazy
stupid love okay do you want to set it
up or um this is a clip where ryan
gosling and i are in a gym and he is
schooling me on the ways of being a real
man okay
let's take a look at that
clip christ look let's face it
all right the war between the sexes is
over and we won
okay
we won the second women started doing
pole dancing for exercise but even
though we won they still deserve our
respect you know make them feel
beautiful actually listen to their
problems open the door for them could
you put on some clothes please oh i'm
sorry is this bothering you no it's not
count it's not bothering you we got a
bigger problem
okay it bothers me i don't care
what you're saying
all right
you know what i have a really good
feeling about this really yeah i like
this a lot really and i i will do you
know what i'm gonna go on record right
now and say i will do this show yes i'm
gonna do it
it's so exciting
that's fantastic yes
what about what do you think uh well can
you come on next week no no let's not
push it okay
it will take a break but thank you for
testing this out steve carell everybody
we'll be right back james franco